[Musique]
bonjour jean marc jancovici bonjour
merci d'être mon invité ce matin sur rmc
et bfm tv vous êtes diplômé de l'école
polytechnique enseignant à l'école des
mines de paris membre du haut conseil
pour le climat et vous présidez un think
tank qui s'appelle the shift project
vous êtes spécialiste de l'énergie en
fait ce que je voudrais comprendre avec
vous aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'il se joue
non seulement aujourd'hui avec bien sûr
la question du gaz et du pétrole russes
mais aussi ce qui se joue demain demain
comment on va faire pour se chauffer
comment on va faire pour rouler comment
on va faire pour produire le contexte
d'abord c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya ce
sommet européen réuni à versailles
aujourd'hui et demain avec un objectif
l'autonomie énergétique vis-à-vis de la
russie et puis il ya bien sûr
l'inquiétude on va y revenir autour des
sites nucléaires en ukraine et la
sécurisation de tchernobyl en fait il ya
dix ans j'ai regardé dans dans tout ce
que vous avez écrit il ya dix ans déjà
vous prédisiez un choc pétrolier et vous
des rouliers de manière assez implacable
le scénario hausse des prix de l'énergie
l'inflation chute de la consommation
récession appauvrissement des classes
moyennes et sur le plan géopolitique
pression migratoire et dérive
autoritaire est ce qu'on y est
pour savoir si on est en fait il faut
repartir du début qui est pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas si difficile que ça
de faire ce genre de prévisions en fait
le monde dans lequel nous vivons nous
l'avons basé sur les combustibles
fossiles même en france où on adore
parler du nucléaire en fait on est
massivement dépendant des combustibles
fossiles pour partie ceux qui sont chez
nous et pour partie ceux qui sont chez
les autres pour fabriquer tous les
objets qu'on importe par exemple et ce
monde il est très difficile à changer de
façon rapide donc à la question vous
avez sûrement me pose est qui et comment
on fait pour se passer du gaz pour se
passer du pétrole etc en fait en une
semaine on s'en passe pas en annonçant
passe pas en disant on s'en passe par
enfant en tout cas pas dans un monde
tranquille
du coup on n'est plus dans un monde
tranquille j'ai dit ce que je veux dire
c'est papa en papa en mode tant qu ils
plus exactement comment est ce qu'on
fait et pardon soûlard pose la question
comment est ce qu'on fait pour s'en
passer parce que malgré tout vous vous
disiez on aura 30 ans on va pas avoir 30
ans pour savoir comment on s'en fout
comment on fait pour s'en passer sans
contrepartie on fait pas voilà c'est là
on est au stade où ses jours ne peut pas
fermer le robinet comme ça d'un coup
sans contrepartie non pour rappeler les
enjeux la russie c'est un tiers du
pétrole qu'on importe en europe l'union
européenne si on exclut la norvège et la
grande-bretagne qui n'en font pas partie
importe 96% de son pétrole 1 donc on n'a
rien chez doux donc le pétrole importé
en europe c'est un tiers qui vient de
russie le gaz importé en europe c'est
40% qui vient de russie dans les deux
cas de figure la source domestique de
production du pétrole et du gaz c'est la
mer du nord la mer du nord est en déclin
depuis 2000 sur le pétrole est en déclin
depuis 2005 sur le gaz on n'a pas de
réserve donc à on a composé la recherche
du pétrole c'est comme les autres
paquets vous savez vous cherchez les
autres packs vous rappeler on trouve
d'abord les plus gros et les moins bien
planqués et puis plus le temps passe et
plus vous trouvez des petits et très
bien planqué dans la recherche du
pétrole et du gaz c'est pareil d'abord
on trouve des gros gisement facile à
exploiter
puis plus le temps passe plus on trouve
des trucs qui sont ou petits ou bien
planqués et donc c'est plus compliqué
puis à un moment il n'ya plus parce
qu'il faut des dizaines ou des centaines
de millions d'années pour faire du
pétrole et du gaz comment il a pu donc
le fait de savoir qu'on allait devoir
faire avec moins de pétrole et de gaz
c'est écrit depuis le début le pétrole
et le gaz sont épuisables et même si on
veut pas s'en passer pour des causes
climatiques à un moment on va devoir
s'en passer pour cause de justin a pu
quoi bon sauf que là il ya une
accélération évidemment et géopolitique
le y en a plus après c'est la boule de
cristal pour savoir d'où ça vient c'est
à dire ça peut venir par épuisement
tranquille des gisements ça peut venir
par rupture instantanée
d'approvisionnement parce qu on est en
bisbille avec le pays producteurs ça
peut venir pour encore d'autres raisons
ça peut venir par exemple pour qu'ovide
l'année du coc vide les investissements
dans l'amont pétrolier ont été divisés
par deux les nouveaux projets et du
reste ceci alors avec cela les
découvertes de pétrole et de gaz en 2021
n'ont jamais été aussi basses depuis des
dizaines d'années
donc ça peut venir de on sait pas
exactement d'où ça peut venir ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça viendra et que ça
viendra à des échéances qui sont pas
longues c'est à dire que j'ai écrit ça
il ya dix ans il ya dix ans on savait
déjà que le maximum de la production
mondiale de pétrole il serait dans la
décennie 2020-2030 et c'est à peu près
ce qu'il va se passer moi je voudrais
quand même comprendre jean marc
jancovici si j'écoute bien votre réponse
vous mais dit non on peut pas s'en
passer on peut pas s'en passer
immédiatement peut pas s'en passer tout
de suite sauce contre ça veut dire quoi
contrepartie c'est sur cet examen si on
a par exemple un tiers de pétrole en
moins en france demain matin
une partie des gens qui se chauffent au
fioul se chauffent moins white de
chauffer une partie des gens qui se
déplacent en voiture n'utilisent plus
leur voiture pour se déplacer donc ils
vont prendre la voiture du voisin ou
bien ils prennent les transports en
commun ou bien ils prennent un vélo ou
bien ils restent chez eux ou bien enfin
par la force des choses j'ai envie de
dire ce qu'il rate tout simplement plus
les moyens de trouver de quoi recharger
en voiture parce qu'un aura moins très
très exactement parce qu'un aura moins
sauf qu'il ya donc cette décision qui va
être prise sans doute aujourd'hui ou
demain une les américains les anglais
ont décidé de couper l'approvisionnement
russe pour leur part les européens
rechignent à prendre cette décision vous
disiez parce que notamment il y à cette
grande dépendance pas temps de nous mais
des allemands voire même des finlandais
qui sont carrément à 100% dépendant des
des russes pourtant vous avez cette
tribune du prix nobel de physique 2012
serge haroche qui hier 10 en coupant le
gaz et le pétrole russe oui nous allons
avoir froid mais nous pourrons nous
regarder en face avec moins de honte il
ya françois hollande l'ancien président
qui dit pour arrêter vladimir poutine
arrêtons nettement de lui acheter du gaz
qui sous leur dise ça vous fait rien
alors on me fait bien marrer oui pardon
de l'expression non mais parce que quand
il était président il a fait tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient pour favoriser le gaz
au détriment du nucléaire les systèmes
énergétiques sont des systèmes qui sont
des systèmes lent et donc ce qu'on est
en train de réaliser maintenant c'est
que si on n'agit pas avec un préavis de
plusieurs dizaines d'années au moment où
les emmerdements arrive on peut juste
les subir savez les systèmes
énergétiques c'est un peu comme
l'éducation d'un enfant si pendant vingt
ans vous avez pas fait ce qu'il fallait
vous corrigez pas le tir en une semaine
ni en six mois ni même en un an eh bien
là c'est exactement pareil on ne peut
pas tout reconfigurer en l'espace de
quelques mois ni même en l'espace d'une
année et si on décide de se passer du
pétrole et du gaz russe une partie de 20
la contrepartie sera pour sera de la
souffrance pour partie il y aura de la
souffrance oui bien sûr il y aura de la
souffrance il y aura on entendait des
efforts qui seront demandés à nous tous
au fond oui bien sûr alors
proportionnellement plus toujours c'est
toujours pareil aux gens qui sont dans
le bas de l'échelle aux gens qui sont
très dépendants de leur voiture pour se
déplacer vous et moi on habite dans un
tissu urbain où c'est très facile de se
déplacer sans voiture déplacent en
voiture et c'est pas un exploit c'est
juste très facile pour moi de le faire
il ya beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui
sont pas dans cette situation là les
gens dans le monde rural par exemple qui
sont pas nécessairement les gens qui
gagnent le plus d'argent sont beaucoup
plus dépendant de la voiture et si vous
leur dites ça serait mieux d'avoir une
voiture électrique ce qui est
parfaitement vrai les ventes de voitures
électriques ces dernières années ont été
plus importantes dans le monde rural que
dans le monde urbain puisque c'est assez
bien adapté sauf que en une semaine vous
équiper pas tout le monde la voiture
électrique ni même en un an donc il ya
déjà des affaires de il ya des délais en
gros c'est bien ça qu'il faut revoir le
système a beaucoup d'inertie et donc ils
demandent de l'anticipation dans ce
qu'on peut reprocher aujourd'hui à une
partie des pouvoirs publics et une
partie des décideurs économiques c'est
d'avoir un peu fermé les yeux sur
quelque chose qui était parfaitement pad
à table mais prévisible dans sa galerie
ce défi qui vous lisent réviser le
disait déjà il ya dix ans il est dans sa
nature et on a rien qu'on n'a pas prévu
de plan b pour moi j'ai pas tellement
envie qu'on regarde vers le passé j'ai
envie qu'on regarde ce qui se passe
demain si en effet à la sortie de ce
sommet de versailles il est décidé que
les européens se donnent six mois ou un
an pour stopper toutes importations
d'hydrocarbures russes soyons très
concret quand vous entendez la patronne
d'énergie qui dit est bien l'une des
solutions d'une des réponses c'est de
demander aux français de baisser leur
chauffage d'un degré est-ce que ça c'est
une solution une des contreparties dont
vous parlez alors c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne oui quand vous baisser le
chauffage d'un degré en robes ou fait
cet avis % d'économie en termes
d'énergie consommée donc vous voyez vous
baisser de 4 degrés 87,28 dont vous avez
économisé à peu près un tiers de
l'énergie de chauffage que vous utilisez
ça veut dire que vous passez votre
température de consigne de 19 à 15 de 19
à 15 ça ça vous paraît jeu acceptable je
ne sais pas si c'est ça c'est la vrai le
seuil de souffrance pour reprendre le
sens des mots que vous disiez ça dépend
des individus certains individus
supporte très bien de vivre 15 certains
individus j'en fais partie supporte même
très bien de dormir dans une pièce dans
laquelle il fait moins de 15
par contre resté immobile pour
travailler dans une pièce dans laquelle
il fait 15 là au bout du au bout de
quelques heures mais là à vous
concentrer commencé à avoir un peu froid
donc ça ça dépend vraiment des individus
ça dépend de ce qu'il est capable de
faire sa défaveur conséquence sur le
chauffage conséquences sur les prix vous
parliez de tous ceux qui sont dépendants
dans la voiture quand on regarde qu'eux
non de nombreuses pompes à essence de
france maintenant ça y est ça a dépassé
les 2 euros y compris pour le gazole ces
prix vont continuer à augmenter ils vont
continuer à augmenter jusqu'au moment où
il y aura de ce qu'on appelle de la
destruction de demande c'est à dire que
les prix deviendront suffisamment élevé
pour qu'une partie des gens ne puissent
plus avoir accès à leurs noms seront
exactement il renonce le mans alors la
partie à laquelle c'est le plus facile
de renoncer au début c'est les
déplacements non contraints ce qu'on a
les loisirs les vacances etc et au bout
d'un moment ça peut également tapé dans
ce qu'on appelle les déplacements
contraints le fait d'aller au travail et
à ce moment on va devoir s'organiser
autrement il ya quelques mois le chi
project a sorti un plan de
transformation de l'économie française
qui est le résultat de deux ans de
travail dans lequel on propose comment
on peut sortir de l'essentiel des
combustibles fossiles en france mais en
trente ans pas en un an alors pourquoi
en 30 ans parce que même en 30 ans et un
effort soutenu très important sortir des
combustibles fossiles en 30 ans en
france ça veut dire que l'utilisation de
ces combustibles baisse de 5% par an en
eau 5% de baisse c'est ce qu'on a eue
l'année du coc vide en 2020 donc vous
voyez le coup de frein qu'il faut mettre
sur l'économie pour qu'on ait 5% de
baisse enfin en france à être un peu
plus de 5% dans le monde mais en gros
c'est le genre d'effort qu'il faut
répéter tous les ans il faut rajouter 5
% tous les ans si on veut pouvoir à
l'économie française dame hors de
question de se dé carbonée ce qui par
ailleurs est la trajectoire qu'on
devrait suivre si on est sérieux sur
l'accord de paris et recuit si on est
sérieux sur la corde parier si on veut
éviter les fameux 2 degrés de hausse de
la délégation de la température moyenne
température à laquelle on a déjà quand
même perdu 20 à 30 % d'humidité des sols
en france il ya plus deux êtres ya plus
d'épicéa une bonne partie des chaînes
qui ont disparu une bonne partie des
pays du sud de la méditerranée en
agriculture qui se met à vraiment
souffrir la quasi totalité des corps aux
mondiaux sont morts à 2 degrés
donc on n'est pas en train de parler de
peccadilles main si on veut limiter la
hausse à 2 degrés il faut que l'on
baisse les émissions de 5 % par an donc
qu'on prenne le problème par le bon
climat tic ou qu'on le prenne par le
bout dépendance à des combustibles
fossiles exigé aux politiques de toute
façon la solution est la même il faut
mettre en oeuvre un plan un plan
systémique un plan qui est qui va
concerner tout le monde partout et tout
le temps mais pardon j'insiste mais ça
doit se faire de manière spécifique
maddox en fait on vous sent très bien
leur nom
ils soyons très clairs jean marc
jancovici vous aviez fait des plans à
long terme avec vous aviez alerter sauf
que maintenant il n'est plus temps
d'alerté il est temps d'agir est dans
l'urgence ce qui ce qui va se passer je
vous fiche mon billet c'est qu'on ne se
passera pas de la totalité du pétrole et
du gaz russe il ne rompt pas ni la force
ni le courage ni la possibilité enfin ça
engendrera une récession qui sera
beaucoup trop importante si alors allons
au bout de votre logique si on
supprimait comme
certains le demandent toute importation
de gaz et de pétrole russe alors
l'europe plongera en récession c'est
évident c'est évident oui le qu'est ce
que c'est que l'énergie l'énergie c'est
ce qui permet aux machines de
fonctionner qu'est-ce qui fait la
production aujourd'hui c'est les
machines je veux dire vous êtes habillé
je suis habillée par des choses qui
sortent de machines à votre micro il a
été fait par une machine cette table a
été faite par une machine toutes les
caméras qui nous films sont des machines
faites par des machines le vous mangez
des choses qui ont été produites par des
machines donc l'énergie elle est
absolument partout autour de nous
aujourd'hui elle fait fonctionner le
monde donc si vous dites on va
brutalement se passer d'un tiers de la
nourriture pour machines ça veut dire
qu'on se passe brutalement d'un tiers du
parc de machines en activité bien
évidemment que c'est récessif est ce que
ces graves d'allergie faute si on
souffrirait pas le plus en récession oui
de cette récession la de cette réunion
organisée par un manque d'énergie tout
le monde ça toucherait absolument tout
le monde parce que ça veut dire moins de
disponibilité pour tous les objets les
aliments alors si on renouvelle moins
souvent le smartphone n'est pas très
grave si on a une garde-robe un peu
moins remplissent pas très grave s'il ya
une pénurie alimentaire s'est beaucoup
nous raconte s'il ya une inflation
alimentaire extrêmement forte c'est
beaucoup plus grave actuellement donc ça
va vraiment pas c'est c'est une
situation un peu inédite
donc c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de
regarder dans une boule de cristal et de
vous expliquer très exactement ce qui va
se passer il ya aussi cette question
effectivement de dans quel jardin est ce
qu'on va chercher les autres packs si je
reprends votre votre métaphore parce
qu'il y avait le jardin russe où on a
été chercher des grosses de pâques si on
se passe de ses oeufs de pâques là on a
quand même l'impression que les
rapprochements géopolitique assez
opportun entre les etats-unis et l'iran
tout d'un coup qui pourrait lever les
sanctions entre les états unis et le
venezuela qui pourrait également lever
les sanctions c'est pour aller chercher
du pétrole alternatif aaa qui est très
compliqué à exploiter le venezuela
revendiquent les premières réserves
mondiales mais c'est du pétrole qui
ressemble pas à du pétrole en fait ils
ressemblent à du miel
le pétrole est liquide il est contenu
dans des gisements qui soit au milieu de
l'amazonie très compliqué à exploiter et
le venezuela a beau revendiquer les
premières réserves mondiales il est en
décrue de production le venezuela depuis
des décennies donc les pays vers
lesquels on pourrait se retourner c'est
une affaire d'ordre de grandeur derrière
ne sont absolument pas capable de
fournir en volume ne sont pas
suffisantes non là dessus finalement de
qualité les gisements sont pas là ou
alors ils sont tellement compliqués à
exploiter que ça ne permettra pas de
compenser les volumes du pétrole ont ils
ont quoi ton à pour caricaturer les
américains qui redeviennent presque
copain avec les vénézuéliens et les
iraniens c'est un peu peine perdue parce
que toute façon ça n'aura même pas
vraiment de quoi compenser de toute
façon ça ne concerne pas nous
directement si les américains deviennent
copain avec les iraniens c'est pour
acheter du pétrole pour j'imagine c'est
pas pour acheter du pétrole pour nous
donc ce sera même pas pour nous aider
les réserves de pétrole américains il en
avait et hier il ya eu plusieurs
annonces disant qu' elle se réduisait
plus rapidement qu'il ne l'imaginait le
pétrole aux états unis il est exploité
de devenir différentes il ya ce qu'on
appelle le pétrole conventionnel le
pétrole qu'on a exploité pendant très
très longtemps qui est un pétrole qui
est contenu dans les roches réservoir
como confort or une roche réservoir
c'est de la cresse et du grêle c'est ce
qu'on appelle le gaz de schiste non non
non après
essai ses réservoirs donc on fait un
gros trou dont fait un forage et puis
après on fait sortir le pétrole et puis
au bout d'un moment il sort pas
volontiers donc on fait comme les
shadoks pompe on injecte de l'eau en
injecte du gaz etc
le pétrole qui aujourd'hui s'est très
fortement développée aux états unis si
pas celui-là c'est ce qu'on appelle le
pétrole de roche mère c'est à dire qu'il
est toujours prisonnier dans la roche où
il a été formé ce que le pétrole se
forment par enfouissement de débris
organiques sous terre que la géothermie
est ensuite cuit à petit feu et la
roche-mère et pour que le pétrole soit
libéré il faut la fracture est d'où la
fameuse fracturation hydraulique dont on
a entendu parler et le gaz de schiste
est pareils pétrole et gaz de schiste et
pétrole et gaz de roche mère tout ça
c'est pareil c'est des hydrocarbures
formé dans la roche mère qui sont restés
prisonniers dans la roche mère et il
faut fracturer pour les faire sortir
c'est ça qui a considérablement augmenté
aux etats-unis ces derniers temps mais
c'est extrêmement capitalistique et donc
c'est une industrie dans laquelle en
compte la production est en train
d'augmenter les gens perdent de l'argent
en gros et donc à un moment les
actionnaires aux états unis on dit
maintenant ça suffit la plaisanterie
give the money back est donc la seule
manière pour ces exploitants de pétrole
et de gaz de schiste de gagner de
l'argent c'est d'arrêter de forêt en
permanence et à ce moment
malheureusement la production diminue ou
s'arrêtent d'augmenter donc c'est très
paradoxal c'est un métier dans lequel si
vous augmentez la production et donc
vous avez de l'énergie pour les machines
ailleurs les gens qui font sortir le
pétrole perdent de l'argent et si les
gens qui font sortir le pétrole va les
gagner de l'argent il soit obligé de
mettre un coup de [ __ ] de frein sur la
production tôt qu'on le voit bien c'est
pas là qu'est l'avenir alors c'est là
qu'ils tuent une partie de l'avenir
o'shea project on a fait on a confié à
deux anciens patrons enfin deux anciens
dirigeants de total il ya maintenant un
peu plus d'un an une analyse très
détaillée d'une base de données de
l'ensemble des gisements de pétrole et
de gaz dans le monde enfin de pétrole
surtout à l'époque et on leur a demandé
de nous faire un pronostic sur ce cas
les produire ces pays là à l'avenir
c'était avant évidemment le choc
craignant et le résultat qu'ils nous ont
fournis républicain il est disponible
sur le site du shit project c'est que la
production de ces pays allait se
stabiliser un peu en dessous du niveau
pré co vide avant de commencer a très
fortement décliné à partir de 2030 quoi
qu'on fasse quoi qu'on fasse et quelles
que soient les situations qui maintenant
évidemment exactement donc simplement
changer la situation actuelle est un
accélérateur de ce que nous allons
devoir faire mais malheureusement on
aurait enfin malheureusement ou
heureusement on aurait dû le faire ça a
plus ou moins
jean marc jancovici il ya eu des
inquiétudes hier sur l'alimentation
électrique du site nucléaire de
tchernobyl puisque l'alimentation
électrique a été complètement coupée le
gendarme onusien du nucléaire nous dit
que cet incident ne présente pas
d'impact majeur sur la sécurité moi ce
qui m'inquiète c'est mot majeur
a un impact vous savez qu'il ya une
échelle de classification des incidents
et accidents en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire et ça va de 1 à 7 ban zorro 0
à 7 en fonction de la gravité de
l'incident ou l'accident et c'est comme
pour une voiture si vous accrochez votre
voisin en vous garance est pas
exactement comme si vous rentrez dans un
mur à 100 km heure bon c'est moins
majeur c'est bon mais c'est un incident
tout de même oui enfin éventuellement si
derrière ça dégénère en pugilat cela
peut devenir très désagréable parce que
vous avez accroché le pare-chocs de
quelqu'un d'autre mais ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter je ne suis pas compétent
pour vous répondre parce que en
l'occurrence c'est le gendarme du
nucléaire qui est compétent pour fournir
la réponse la seule chose que je peux
vous dire c'est que vu des russes je ne
vois pas quel serait leur intérêt à
provoquer un gros problème à tchernobyl
parce que leur envie c'est pas
d'éradiquer l'ukraine c'est de l'annexé
ou de la mettre à leurs bottes et pour
ça il faut qu'ils aient un pays en ordre
de marche et donc un pays en ordre de
marche ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
créée sur place un pépin qui qu'on ne
peut pas corriger derrière voilà
espérons donc que les prises de
décisions sont rationnels donc donc j'ai
envie de dire à ce stade je vois pas
quelle serait la logique pour les russes
de provoquer un incident majeur sur
place une question encore sur les
alternatives au nucléaire puisque vous
faites partie de ceux qui disent qu'au
fond le moindre mal c'était quand même
de pouvoir produire avec le nucléaire de
l'électricité on a le commissaire
européen france timmerman qui dit à la
veille donc de ce sommet européen qu'il
faudra développer massivement l'éolien
et le solaire est ce que c'est vraiment
une solution je vais commencer pour par
une réponse pour montrer que c'est pas
si simple que ça l'allemagne est le pays
européen qui a le plus investi dans
l'éolien et le solaire sur les vingt
dernières années ils ont mis 1000
milliards d'euros en gros
non pas 2 millions entre 500 et 1000
entre 500 et 1000 donc ça fait un énorme
paquet d'argent quand même et pour
autant ils sont aujourd'hui en plus
dépendants exactement au gaz donc ce
donc il suffit par à 2 sans compter que
là on a fait un effort massif en faveur
des renouvelables dans une économie qui
exportait assez bien or maintenant on va
devoir faire un effort massif dans une
économie qui va moins bien se porter
puisque comme je les dis l'économie
dépend des combustibles fossiles et même
s'il n'y avait pas eu la guerre en
ukraine ça va devenir beaucoup plus
rock'n'roll sur ce plan là donc on va
devoir transitionner pour l'essentiel
avec une économie en contraction c'est
ça qu'il faut bien avoir en tête et
déployer massivement les nerfs dans ce
genre de contexte c'est-à-dire les
énergies renouvelables aux vernets
renouvelables oui c'est une question
pour laquelle aujourd'hui personne n'a
la réponse c'est à dire personne ne sait
si si facile on sait que c'est facile
d'en faire et encore pas de manière
suffisante dans un monde dans lequel il
ya de l'argent dans un monde dans lequel
il ya moins de moyens est ce que c'est
toujours aussi facile c'est pas évident
donc le cocktail sur lequel il va
falloir jouer c'est des économies des
renouvelables et du nucléaire et aucun
de ces trois pieds là du tabouret net un
pied qu'on peut exclure par contre la
part de chaque pied en fonction du
secteur en fonction de l' usage en
fonction de la situation de départ elles
varient et il va falloir tenter tous de
faire un effort de consommation
finalement vous emmener le don va devoir
faire des efforts de sobriété de toutes
façons d effort de sobriété et vous
aviez quand même dit aussi ce mot de
souffrance ça n'ira pas sans souffrance
je retiens quand même jean marc
jancovici que vous le dites je vous
fiche mon billet m'avez vous dit qu'il
ne se passeront pas du gaz et du pétrole
russes réponse donc aujourd'hui totalité
et demain en totalité réponse donc
aujourd'hui et pas mal de déclarations
on nous parle de ce qu'il avance passé
j'ai bien compris et on peut compter sur
vous pour avoir cette vigilance merci
infiniment d'avoir répondu précisément à
mes questions ce matin je voudrais
signaler également votre livre c'est
sous forme de bande dessinée ça
s'appelle le monde sans fin c'est paru
en octobre dernier aux éditions dargaud
et c'est un livre passionnant merci à
vous il est 8 heures 53